[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
explosion des données comment prévenir
la submersion
en 2010 la quantité de données créées et
échangées dans le monde était de deux
états octets en 2025 elle atteindra 180
états octets c'est dire si l'air actuel
de la civilisation du Big Data est
marquée par les 3V volume vélocité et
variétés des données les opportunités
que présentent l'exploitation des méga
donnés sont nombreuses dans les domaines
de la santé des transports des sciences
du marketing mais cette évolution pose
différents problèmes au sein de nos
sociétés avertit le sénateur Ludovic
quai dans une note scientifique sur
l'explosion des données faites au nom de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
lopex il invite à prévenir le risque de
submersion
car l'impact environnemental des outils
numériques croient de 6% par an causant
au moins 3,5% des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre et 4,2% de la
consommation mondiale d'énergie primaire
par ailleurs l'explosion des données
encouragent une surcharge
informationnelle qui entraîne stress
épuisement addiction et moindre
créativité
notre durée d'attention sur un sujet
serait ainsi réduite à quelques secondes
sur le plan politique l'accélération de
la production de données favorise la
domination des entreprises et des Data
Center américain ou encore les risques
de surveillance de masse
en outre elle engendre de nouvelles
inégalités sociales relèvent l'Office
afin de limiter les effets de
l'explosion des données l'OPEX formule
plusieurs recommandations dans le sens
d'une sobriété numérique la recherche de
solutions technologiques pour prévenir
et contenir l'explosion des données et
la surcharge informationnelle doit se
renforcer notamment la recherche sur
l'agrégation et la curation de données
mais ce que préconise surtout l'OPEX
c'est d'engager un combat culturel pour
limiter l'accumulation obsessionnelle de
données véritable syndrome de Diogène
numérique ainsi l'auteur de la note
scientifique suggère de développer
l'hygiène numérique tant à l'échelle
individuelle qu'au niveau des
entreprises et des administrations
cela passerait notamment par le
nettoyage régulier de ces données en ce
sens la législation sur la protection
des données pourrait être renforcée et
s'accompagner d'une plus grande
pédagogie recommande l'OPEX
en toile de fond la maîtrise des effets
directs et indirects de l'explosion des
données plaides en faveur d'une
gouvernance française et européenne des
données et de leurs infrastructures
ainsi que de la promotion du droit à la
déconnexion
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]